I'm going to talk a little bit today
about outgoing NYC calm which was a
personal project I did to take a look at
where the LG LG BT night life had been
throughout history in New York City and
I'll first will tell you a little bit
about Who I am I am I work for Carter DB
which is a geospatial database which
allows you to put interactive maps on
the web very very easily I'm their new
york city business development manager
i'm also an instructor in the g sap
program and i teach details of the
digital city which is a project where
we're looking at individual blocks in
new york city and doing a deep deep deep
dive into 311 data and open data
anything we can find on the internet and
put those into a nice big project to to
do some investigation on how you can
make open data tell stories and on that
with these two things together we have
just added a site license for her to DB
for the Columbia for everybody so go
there and sign up if you want to check
out credit eb i'll be talking a little
bit about it i'm going to focus more on
the project but if you have questions
about party to be i can handle them
afterwards or just let me know you can
find me easily so first of all what is
outgoing outgoing is a map that
stretches from 1859 to now of every LGBT
nightlife spot in New York's history
this is an image of it and I think what
we'll do is we're just going to go right
there and take a look at it and then
I'll tell you a little bit about my
process why I made it and why i think
it's it's important to do this and then
we'll talk a little mask some questions
and talk about
a little bit so here you can see it's
it's basically it's a map it's an
interactive map of all these different
locations these are all the bars that
have been in the city from 1859 and
might have a hard time into the text
under so I'll just say it aloud 1859 to
2015 and it's as you go in to the map
you can actually explore different
neighborhoods you can zoom into
individual places you can click on a bar
itself and find out a little bit more
about it and these are all collected
through various sources and means which
I'll go through in a few moments you can
also do geolocation and this works on
your mobile phone really really nicely
you can actually go to anywhere in the
city and find out where you are there
were no gay bars throughout history here
that we've found yet inside Colombia but
there's the gold rail a little bit south
of here let's see when I could open and
closed it was actually almost no this
1965 to in 1980 approximately which I'll
talk about why I do that and then just
the right of us here we've got this was
actually a great area a certain point on
braised and Jays so there you go so as
you're walking around the city you can
go to the site you can just press the
little geolocation button say like hold
it was a gay bar here in 1940 and it's
it's really it's kind of fun I do it all
the time but back to the discussion
about it so I kind of want to talk a
little bit about why I made this it's a
really it's an interesting project of
course right to kind of know about where
the history of things are and dealing
with time and space and interactive
mapping is kind of hard because there's
not really a good
to make sure everything kind of comes up
at the right time and it is shown
properly so what I I'm not the first
person to do this and I'm not the most
recent person to do this there's day
after the New York Public Library just
hired time and space engineer Burke over
there and he's really wonderful guy and
he's looking really deeply at the how
and why of time and data so he's going
into the collections and he's going to
be mimicking a little bit of what I did
and I maybe I mimic him I don't know but
we're working together now anyway so
going into old books and old yellow
pages and old references and anything
that the the library has been collecting
for hundreds of years enough thousands
of hundreds of years and extracting that
data and then making it relational so
that you can see relationships between
you know a phone book and police records
and all kinds of stuff so what I'm
trying to do here is to make to reveal a
little bit of gay history so that I
could better understand myself and
understand the relationship of gay
people to the rest of society so my
career has been in mostly in mapping i
went to CCA in california was trained as
a designer and I nobody was awaited 2001
after going back I studied geology for a
while and that didn't work out and what
back instead of design and I was the
only person doing information and
mapping in 2001 because was so hard it
was really really hard to do as we was
kind of just becoming a thing and it was
expensive and so I did a lot of stuff by
hand and my final thesis was basically a
like a labyrinth a dirt labyrinth we
denied it we didn't use any digital
tools except for illustrator we just
kind of do all that by hand and so I
when I graduated I went I work for
Newsweek here in the city and
I ended up getting into a lot of really
great projects working with some people
who are very very skilled and had been
doing information graphics and mapping
for dozens of years and so I ended up
learning some of the best Bonnie
Scranton and it was one of them she
worked with Edward Tufte and so how many
a little tricks so there's a map of La
showing when the the new Giri building
was being built like how excited
everybody was what about it this is the
one on the bottom left is solving the
malaria problem and some new advances in
malaria and on the right is HIV rates in
India and how are they retired to truck
routes and and how they were they were
dealing with that after that I worked
for regional plan Association which
didn't work with a lot of urban planning
issues and did things like the
governor's island guidebook so I deep
into the city and all of these these
were laying a foundation for me to do a
lot of the work I'm doing now and then I
when I did my own I ran my own business
called line point pathway I did a whole
bunch of different really wonderful
pieces and finally ended up working for
card ODB but in in that process I ended
up learning a lot about productivity and
did so this is an open data project that
I did called is for the sweetened calm
which is a consumer to business umer to
business renovation contractor
innovation assignment that's like a
trust network for contractors and people
who want to build out their homes and so
we did a whole bunch of data work and
pulled out all of the building permits
that had ever been created in New York
City which kind of was the inception of
outgoing for me for this this map was
the closest thing to it and so I did
this and I thought what else could be
mad what else is something that's
important to me and then finally we did
I did this this was his one here though
that one was to split this might know
okay he worked on this project with me
this was a city bike called ridden
center and they were one of my clients
and Britain center is the transportation
think tank over at NYU and they said hey
we're coming we're gonna release all of
our data and we want somebody to do
something interesting with it so they
asked me to jump in and help out and we
made 48 hours of riding city bike in New
York City so basically this starts at
12am on September 17th and you can see
people picking up bikes and we did
basically ordered a destination is it
too late you can see people picking up
pikes dropping them off and
let's go let's fast forward a little bit
too plus 6 30 watch penn station blow up
it's really good it's kind of amazing
give me the chills every time what
happens so those are all new jersey
people coming into New York picking up
city bikes and running around town so we
made this in processing and it's we
could only do video because processing
is kind of hard to do to make anything
interactive with so there's that so you
can check that that's actually on the
site if you wanted to check it out even
further but I'm going to move on from it
and finally 1996 I had actually made a
gay guide for San Francisco one of my
friends when I first entered design
school my one of my friends said hey
there's not a really good gay guy for
the city and gay guys are important for
cities or worm or even a decade ago
because it's an orientation device
because it was really for a long time it
was very dangerous to be gay and we all
kind of know that history just a little
bit maybe where it was actually they
were it was illegal to concrete with
more than two gay people next to each
other in parts of the 60s and so you
really had to be a very delicate and so
these these structures came out to help
people find each other and find places
to go out to be safe and so there was a
long tradition of gay guys that came out
damron as one of them and also a whole
host of them later but in 1996 I was
approached by this man named Kim to said
I want to make one for San Francisco
that's really good that you carry around
in your back pocket because it's small
and you can just take it with you
everywhere so this that is about that
size of that
and I designed this with him and it was
really thrilling experience because it
helped identify basically you were every
quarter you were doing a summary of the
gay scene in the city and so we would
pull all these maps out and at the time
in 1996 the pulk was still the
neighborhood that people used in to go
out Union Square soma and so we would go
through and we would visit all of the
bars every every quarter and we would
just kind of verify and and make sure
they were still open and now so so I did
that and now I'm here in New York and I
bit there was a period where I was going
out a lot because I was kind of I had a
lot every time for some no reason and so
I was going on visiting and I was
getting into conversations with older
gay men specifically and they were like
oh thanks for so much better in the 70s
and 80s I was like why and they kind of
said well it was just more fun there
were more bars and people were just a
little bit freer and I thought all right
well let's let's go with that and I
decided to get some data on it so I I
wasn't quite settled with that answer
that it was because I really do feel
like in every generation you know this
is the 70s this is the same which was
like the biggest kiss nightclub you ever
heard of and it was done on sixth and
second and they took basically a movie
theater and added a planetarium inside
of it and it projected onto the ceiling
and there was this sea of gays and
lesbians just dancing and for all night
long no alcohol they didn't actually
drink it was all there were a lot of
club drugs that happened but it was it
was a mix of sober and club drugs and it
was but it was just to kind of be part
of the scene so I can see like talking
to people have been there they're
thrilled that they got to go through it
and I can understand why it would seem
like it was a little bit better than
now but I wanted to kind of get more
information and you know obviously if
things have changed the this is this
from the 70s again and it and the work
that was done by the people in the 70s
has led to us having our freedoms now
that's really important for us to
remember that you know but then also if
you look at other periods like this is
Provincetown in the 40s and they are
having a great time too so I I kind of
feel like there's evidence that the 70s
and 80s may have been a big pinnacle of
the gay experience for nightlife it was
a massive release after a lot of
oppression from the 40s 50s and 60s and
if you look at the number of bars it's
it is definitely a significant but I
don't think we can say it's better and
lesbian New York and the 30s was amazing
and lesbian Eric in this late 60s was
really really amazing bat down on
Bleecker Street so and then if you go
back to the 1890s we're there these are
pin ups from the 89 89 is these are
cheesecake photos basically so it's
which is really kind of great so my
goals for the project were to look
deeply into the gay neighborhoods
president past to understand where the
things were happening and to start a
conversation about where we were going
and what the sort of where we were in
the timeline of the gay experience and
then to collect stories and keep a
record which is frankly the hardest part
unless you have a lot of money so first
of all looking at gay neighborhoods you
know gaining roads are from to find a
lot of different ways and they were they
were created to protect this is how the
simpsons represents gay neighborhoods
and they you know there were a lot of
stereotypes that go with them which can
be fun and can be very dangerous and
it's it was a level of safety was needed
and
and congregation and gay neighborhoods
tended to gravitate towards where there
was lower rent and available space so
that you could actually have a lot of
people join in oops sorry okay that was
my m Lord and so in gaining roads across
in different cities uh take are in
different places obviously New York has
christopher street san francisco has the
castro los angeles as west hollywood in
every city there's a small congregation
center that that you can find a hub of
gay people Atlanta has a great one and
so many people so over time it's shifted
and the number of bars now is much lower
and people are wondering where the next
LGBT neighborhoods in New York City will
be there are predictions for Washington
Heights Bushwick Rockaway Beach Jersey
City the bigger question that I have is
whether we're just heading towards a
different model and whether people are
just sort of incorporating into the rest
of the world and not needing the safety
that come with with neighborhoods before
so some of the theories behind why maybe
gain neighborhoods are dissolving is
that cities are becoming more expensive
making it harder cluster intentionally
so that you can't actually just dive
into a place that said like you know
this is a gay neighborhood you can't
maybe afford to live there because it's
just too hard to break in incomes for
gays have been traditionally lower
specifically for lesbians and it's it's
it's not maybe not possible to to
actually dive into a hood this
established
gays are integrating more socially and
spatially so it's maybe more possible to
get into any neighborhood in to find a
place to live and work and dating apps
are making the dynamic more interested
in interesting making it so that you
don't necessarily need the nightlife
hubs that you had before which I have
some doubts about but it's it's the room
is to be seen so my big question is how
many bars clubs in bath houses are there
now and how does that compare to
previous decades in error there is so if
we look at it let's go to the map again
ok and I'm going to zoom in a little bit
because the screen is a little bit so
let's we're going to just look at
Manhattan
that too monkey all right okay so if we
take this slider here and we look at
1859 you see one bar that is fast and
faps was a great little corner location
and I'm sure there were more than this
but I'm still kind of looking to see if
i could find them the city has this on
their record for LGBT history it was
made in 1899 and I found evidence of
closed in 1864 and there have been three
other gay bars that have landed on that
spot since there's mr. black and then to
others and so there's there's a little
bit of evidence that that that's what
was happening in 1890s so now if you go
a little bit further if we got to say
1890 let's go 1882 1898 1900 to get more
right and the reason the way I'm
defining whether these are gay bars or
not is whether they're called they're a
couple of different words from the
Bohemian their fairy resorts they were
there a lot of different codes codes
that you have to look for so if we zoom
in now we can see that the bleecker area
Bleecker Street was becoming a big place
of congregation there's black rabbit
there's the slide which became sort of a
sex tourism location and that means that
outsiders who were fairly prudish would
come in and they would watch the
activities going on at the slide for
their owner Entertainment's because they
were kind of not willing to participate
themselves they wanted to see it in
action and so that this became a there
were there were actual tours that led
through the black rabbit and slide to
help people better understand what it
was like to be tottering and so then if
you look over here this is the Bowery
this is Columbia paresis haul these this
was the law this is what gave the Bowery
its name of
of debauchery and it was it was quite
popular with New Yorkers and actually
right here it is the greenwich hotel
granite hotel was a place where men came
into the city and had no where they were
fairly anonymous they had nothing going
on they were they were came in looking
for work and they all ended up
gravitating toward each other in this
hotel and what happens when you have a
lot of men in a hotel is that eventually
some same-sex relationships forum and
then you slowly get a neighborhood that
comes out about that the Black Rabbit
was actually a lesbian bar and so this
area quickly turned into and has
remained or remained until about the 60s
a really big lesbian central point of
action central thing of congregation so
let's move forward a little bit to 1910
or actually it's been in 1902 1928 so
you can see a whole bunch more open up
we've got eats hangout which was
apparently a great bar lot written about
it webster hall was the probably the
most popular gay bar in the early night
early part of the 20th century and it
was essentially it would throw a lot of
drag shows that happened there and there
were some clubs up in Harlem that did
the same thing and it's I mean who knew
right cholesterol was was a
gay activity and then if you start going
into the 30s to stuff about the 60s you
can see that a lot of places are open up
right and you can also see that their
places the purple ones or places that
are open now still so in this period we
have some really long running up now we
have some bars have been running for a
very long time so then once you head
into the 60s and 70s let's go up to 60
to 70 you can see the scale just starts
getting much much bigger we're going to
back up a little bit here let's back up
a lot more than that so this is nineteen
sixty 1970 if we go 1972 1980 a lot more
dance right and then nineteen eighty to
nineteen ninety still dance and then it
starts slowing down a little bit because
the bar started closing down after the
AIDS crisis they were there were a lot
of they're basically the bath houses
were shut down so some of the dots have
disappeared for that reason the sex
clubs were definitely closed down that
opened up in the 70s and 80s and so then
if you go into 2000s which I moved here
about two thousand two and I've seen a
lot of bars close to twenty fifteen you
can see that there's a lot less
significantly less and then if you go to
now I haven't actually updated for a
couple of new bars that have opened up
but there we are so and this one just
actually just closed the just about just
closes last year so the numbers show
that there are fewer bars now what to do
with that you know it's is it possible
the bars are changing bars are doing
different things they're serving
different purposes gay people are now
going to straight bars so that's
actually been throughout history that's
been a thing that has happened the plaza
though
room was a was a gay bar for a while and
it was one side of the bar was straight
on by other side the bar was gay but it
was illegal to be gay in this bar so the
straight people protected they protect
them because they enjoyed that this is
the social aspect of it so it's been a
very complex result so here and here
I've just kind of made it a little
easier this was the old I turned off the
lights on this project about eight
months ago I turned it from white to
black just because I should have seen
that in the beginning so in nineteen
sixty 1980 and 2015 you can see the
difference so that surge in the nineteen
eighty was basically just a lot of
freedom so how did I make this so the
tools are a Google spreadsheet synced to
a car to DB table and that car DB table
coded into leaflet HTML CSS and using a
little jQuery for summing interactivity
and the base map is a matte box base map
and it's all stored in a github pages
output and the initial design like I was
saying was was white and then I turned
the the background off how did I collect
the data well so the first thing so the
damage she could jump ahead to the
sources and then I'm going to come back
and show you the so the sources i used
the first thing i did was i scraped a
bunch of books that i have been reading
about the topic when i was starting so i
escaped scraped gay metropolis gay New
York and then otto bock autobiography of
an androgyne just a fascinating book
it's it's basically the story of a fairy
as they were called them and it's just
all the stories that happened to them in
the Bleecker Street area really really
fascinating how dangerous it was to live
and then x squared red x square blue
everyone should read it's a graphic sex
so just be aware of that but it's a
really really good book about exactly
what happened with the theaters in
southern New York and how urban planning
and changing media consumption changed
the sex scene in New York especially
what happened was that the theaters
shifted towards multiplexes that Lincoln
Square in Union Square and so the single
film theaters weren't really useful
anymore and they slowly turned to adult
theaters and those were never maintained
they were lower costs I mean they were
they were they basically relied on just
people coming in and they became sort of
outlets for sex and once they started
falling apart it became a huge blight on
the area and lots of things happen and
they closed down and so these four books
are really amazing references on the
entire process of gay life in New York
City and then a little crowd sourcing
through outgoing NYC if some wonderful
people have helped me refine the project
and then some first person interviews
but I'm going to show you some
individual sources right now so this is
a 1969 gay guide seen gay scene guide
and then which was what is terrific and
you can see sort of how the one that I
did in 1996 echoes this a little bit
without ever having seen it this is the
nineteen sixty-nine New York directory
it's that it just kind of gets great is
all just typewritten
and I think only one of them came out
two more one from 6975 these are their
beautifully designed that the New York
yellowpages sex guide to Manhattan a lot
of posters that that full fold-out
poster so you could keep it on a wall in
a bar club so we could find out find
more this is the let this is the first
of the switchboards so that their
existence these switchboards in New York
City so you could call in a number when
you got here the number for the lesbian
one was 7 for 12 610 no area code and
you could call in and you could find
that say hey I met the carrboro of
bleecker and Houston where's the nearest
lesbian club and they would have these
lists of everything that was going on
this was this is the gay one and they
were updated monthly so you have in the
New York Public Library you have the
guide itself for every year and then you
have the updates so you can actually
gather opening and closing dates from
that data and so I'm actually in the
process of doing two new ones that I
found and so this is an update so page
35 at churches dignity integrity the
mail stop is at 164 Broadway man's
country now has four dollar lockers with
six hour time limit great information
and then and so you know just and then
finally they cuts they started getting
smaller and smaller and higher quality
printing and frankly lost some of the
the charm that they'll be able to attend
I want to go back and talk about the
process so basically when I get one of
these you find the source to scan it in
the beginning I was just transcribing it
so I would go through the book like gay
New York I just basically went through
and I wrote down a couple of friends
helped me out like just writing down
every location that was mentioned so
just looking for clues so without OCR
optical character recognition you go
through the photos of a guidebook and
log every entry marketing
he abducts up its and you have to be a
little bit rigorous but I'm not very
rigorous as a person so I just do my
best with OCR you can read the image and
then do it a ton of cleanup and i'll
show you that process in a second and
you can add cleaned or transcribed
information to spreadsheet so and then I
sink it so then I put it into google
spreadsheet and it sinks in this is one
of the good OCR examples so you have in
midtown you have this list of bars here
and this is what you get my cleans up
just a tiny little bit but not much so
it comes in pretty cleanly and you know
if you have something like this you can
go very very quickly I use prismo for
the Mac it actually has a mac and iOS so
if I find something I can just go to and
then but then you get this it's just
like you know this is partially a
problem of me taking a picture of the
new york public library on a table not i
was i had full permission to do it but I
just didn't have a set up to two
hold the book down and it was a tiny
work with a small band so I have this
picture but he can't read it and so I
basically have to go through in hand
scribe every one of these pieces and I
have all kinds of people trying to help
me with machine learning on this and I'm
like he can't help if the original
pictures bad so and then that goes into
this this this spreadsheet which I can
show you here and so from this
spreadsheet let's go this is oom it a
little bit so you can see it so I have
the source I have whether it's in
business or not which gives it the color
on the map I have the genre genre too so
you have bars clubs restaurants and then
I have secondary and I have secondary
genres I had a tertiary but I didn't
keep it so you have beer bars
neighborhood bars dance bars dance clubs
and then you go into piano bars and so I
just basically identified a bunch of
different types in label them as that
then you have the name locations city
state full location which helps us do
the geolocation here I'll show you how
to do that so basically with Google
Spreadsheets you can add a little macro
that helps you code so I just I uncoated
this one so you can geolocate the cell
so it does that really fast and that is
a it's called gioco if you look in the
google spreadsheets extension so you can
see there's it's called a geocode or
something like that if you can't find it
just email me help I'll show you where
it is and then who the audience was gay
mixed or lesbian this is the weakest
part of my intent the project and
because you I wasn't there so I can't
really tell whether a bar was like
sunday nights it was very lesbian Friday
nights it was very it was a lot of trans
people I can't tell so it makes me
insecure looking at that column face
and then any public descriptions this is
all just this is my editing moment where
I pull quotes out of different I pull
quotes out of different sources and kind
of add them in here and or I just little
notes that I want to do whether or not
they were membership bars membership was
important because the Mafia owned most
of the bars in New York's most of the
gay bars in New York City and there's a
lot of history of that I'm not going to
go into it too much just because I don't
know that much about it and I don't want
to say anything irresponsible but the
membership bars made it legal to have
some of these places and they also
sometimes I had to have food so they you
would see these weird buffets show up on
Sunday afternoons in these really dingy
gay bars that were nobody really wanted
to eat but they had to have it in order
to keep their license so this so then I
have your open your clothes confirmed
because you'd be your open and you're
close with the hardest thing to find
because they weren't really recorded so
some bars you can you know look in
public records and you can see how long
it was but it's it's not always the case
and then finally you're open any or
closed and i have mafia on here ready to
go stonewall was actually true is it on
there so yeah so I I'm ready to go with
with labeling things whether they were
my own because it's just kind of
interesting and then let's see here so
so that syncs to a Carter DB table and
then that renders out of the map it
renders at a table I work that into the
code right here you can see right here
base and basically cardi B does a great
job of pulling into a leaflet instance
and from that you get 989 locations so
far and I know there are more I know
they're probably about 1500 to 2000 so
and I haven't quite gotten all of the
I actually got just got really busy and
so I had to kind of hold back but if
anybody wants to help you please let me
know so what's all the map now is
locations used in nightlife and after
dark and I focused on effort after dark
to keep it simple for myself and that
was where I was interested I could
expand to LGBT organizations that were
open during the day cafes and nonprofits
and that sort of thing but that's
further down and anything that supported
nightlife and then events that were of
cultural significance which is becoming
more and more the case so the modern gay
bar is really an event that happens once
a week or once a month so what it needs
is more sites for the 20s to 60s images
and company materials bars and clubs
that are edge cases haven't bush like
you're having bars that are super mixed
they're very gay and very straight and
it's kind of a great thing to see which
I think might might be a sign of how
people are changing reworking of the
genre field and when I really see that
got a bunch of press it got on BuzzFeed
and Joe my god which I was pretty happy
about and the reason
I've kind of already got over this but I
kind of open up to questions but this is
the st. which was like the best would
like really from what everyone says the
best club in history so that was this is
the planetarium and one of the points
that I really want to make about this is
that what this map was meant to do is to
instigate intergenerational interaction
I the whole project started with Wally
you're who I met at nowhere bar in New
York and he said he's like you guys have
no idea how many places there were and
so we started this conversation and I
kind of built the project right there in
my head and I was like looking for
something to do and but I've always had
a thing where I just I love talking to
older gay men and women and finding out
what they saw because I came I came out
like right at the in the middle of the
AIDS crisis actually and and I just
never saw what it was like before that
so I kind of had to do this project was
a bit of a reconciling for me so I could
understand better what exactly they saw
and people like Wallace a very much
helped me understand it and we already
talked about that and everyone should be
happy that Stonewall and Julius are
looking at being landmarked Julius was a
side of the sit-in before Stonewall's
riot and was possibly the more important
of the two events because it was
basically they tried to sit in different
places and get arrested and the final
one that they did was in Julius they
kept trying over and over again it was
very much like the Rosa Parks scenario
where they they tried to get this this
to happen a couple times and it finally
it did and they were arrested and it
started a big sit-in in a big movement
and that which led to stonewall a little
while later and lastly as I've been
doing this research I've been finding
out that the apps are not that new an
idea gay men and gay women have been
getting in touch through other means for
years so in the 50s the real hobby
supporting my findings or code for like
without preferred for gay and in the
back pages you would see classified ads
I'm going to be for pen pals and it was
so hard to be gay in the 40s 50s and 60s
after McCarthy that they just have a
view everything went underground and so
then in the 1980s but the magothy was
basically print and classifieds for a
long time and then 80s we had VBS
systems and 1 900 numbers 90s AOL from
manhunt and then in the 2000s we
obviously have all these things so the
future I actually the few this is
important the future involves other
other projects that I'm seeing happening
right now this is a NYC daddy map this
is by a friend of mine Elliott Ramos he
basically took the taxi data and zoomed
and basically put it into a database and
Carter dtb actually and did look to
origin destination of everybody that
left the eagle on 28 straight between
the hours of midnight and 5am and looked
at where they went so you can see the
distribution of how people go to and
from bars and then also one of my
students who's here abdullah
did this and he's this is actually the
more profound work that this is better
than how it going for sure he took the
database that I made and I don't know if
he took it holy I think he probably
added a little bit and then looked at
taxi origins and destinations and then
constructed this neighborhood map of
where gay people are living leaving
farms so you can see we can kind of see
them where people are living so you've
got a lot of waiting for a green point
with a lot of Queens and he's done some
demographic analysis on it as well and
it's really really good work so this is
where the percentage men percentage
women and that's it and please ask him
about it because he loves talking about
it so that's it but I have for that um
five minutes but so are there any
questions i can i can help yeah
yeah the spreadsheet to legacy
yeah yes and it's more complex than that
though it is the primary source that I
used in there but sometimes it shows
something like a resource so letting up
Julius has shown up in every source
since 1950
so it's I use just one so I can
reference that's where I first found it
yeah and that's that's one of the
columns and that source is in the map I
just haven't turned off for the moment
because they need to reorganize how it's
numbered and exposed
I'm keeping those separately so pictures
and stories and conversations about a
place
one person in the city who has the
entire scene archive so I have like a
ton of data from there and then stone
wall and Julius but I'm keeping those
sort of in an archive for when I have a
little free time
Thanks it's a I i I've had to drop it a
little bit so because I'm kind of dizzy
and parted eb but it's I'm looking for
inspiration to get started again I mean
yeah
so the cost of opening and maintaining
bars from what I understand effects
lesbian bars the most because they bars
are very expensive to run and you battle
community boards for almost everything
to get a liquor license in a community
where especially community 3 Manhattan
and to Manhattan is really really hard
and it might be part of the reason why
the bars are disappearing because of the
process itself I know that I've spoken
to the owners of several bars in the
spillage and they're like it's just
they're after us and they're not
targeting them because they're gay I've
looked into that to see like I actually
did an analysis on all the bars they
rejected it's not just gay bars but it
adds a cost that is really unnecessary
from what everyone can everyone seems to
feel that you have to get a bar approved
through so many levels and then you see
some of these bro bars just kind of
going up really fast and not having any
problems at all so there's a little bit
of corruption which adds to the cost but
that aside running a bar is really
expensive and so if you look at the
lesbian bars they're on the edges of the
wealthy areas there some of the corners
of the West Village one and Tribeca and
they really have a hard time staying
open and if there are some been some
great articles recently about where the
hell are the lesbian bars going in every
city so this is not just exclusive to
this issue like the gay bars are
disappearing everywhere and so looking
into that issue is kind of important but
you to answer your question i hope i
have a little bit they're just really
are very expensive to run not more the
gay bars are not more expensive to run
than straight bars but they're expensive
and you have to have to work a little
harder to attract i think so getting the
money in is a little bit harder
of an androgyne I can you zoom in on
that one it's a rare it's kind of hard
to find so let's go back all the way
look there it is I'll just let me make
it bigger cuz I
autobiography of an androgyne and the
it's Ralph Werther wor th er it's really
fascinating book and it's the one thing
about this project that I would love to
do more of is more trans more trans
experience more trans history and it's
really hard to find I was just reading a
book on the way here about whether about
how how difficult how it's just been
buried because a lot of times they just
people trans people to never reveal
themselves until they were dead and they
found out that people were actually a
woman or a man upon death so it's hard
to find a lot of trans history but i'm
i'm looking for the sources for that and
that was one of them
ok I think my times up yep a one minute
i would have it one more question yeah
or
and I
apartment this is we're saying
be more organized than I was or I am
it's like tract everything photograph
everything and then come up with a
system if the smart key thing i did i
did that fairly late I was doing it I
was kind of coating everything by hand
Google Spreadsheets great I would say
just be really organized and then don't
be afraid to ask people in archives for
more so like when they say oh oh yeah we
have this I like I went to the LGBT
Center and I pulled all of their gay
guides they've ever had and I asked one
more time and I got a whole box that
they didn't even know about so there's
and that gave me like 300 addresses so
it's it's
Oh got it um photograph them better like
make sure you have really nice straight
if you're going to do OCR nice straight
photographs head on and in brighter
light but a certain point you just deal
with the fonts they were using back in
the 70s and 80s and 90s which are not
necessarily OC arable but you know I
kind of found the hand transcribing the
most satisfying because I just like
going to a library and using the Dewey
Decimal System you find something next
to it so I found a lot of the stories
and really interesting things just by
accident by going through gay New York
and learning a lot about gay New York at
the process and then going through the
gay guides and just finding out things
that weren't necessarily going to go on
the map but I saw them anyway in little
advertisements so I guess my biggest
piece of ice are just enjoy the process
so but with digitizing i use prismo for
OCR it's been the best one i've found so
far and just be very clean with your
career your photography and
that's it so I'm Jeff at Carter DB if
you want to get in touch with me I'm
also zingbot on Twitter and that up
there one more time
all the way to the end oops so yeah so
you can reach me on twitter at zingbot
or Jeff Ricardo TV calm and happy to
answer questions thanks